so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Valiant entertainments
2012 relaunch of EXO Manowar and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of this
video you'll have a strong understanding
of his character as well as how he's
evolved over the years and help to
elevate Valiant to the level of Marvel
and DC in terms of fan popularity
so why did they fought back to my video
on valiant entertainment explained the
origin of XO Man O'War actually has this
history in valiant as a company as well
as Marvel Comics referencing my video on
valiant where Marvel was originally a
subsidiary of magazine management
company under the ownership of Martin
Goodman because magazine management was
losing money
due to the decrease in popularity of
men's magazines and the increase in
popularity of comics another company
named perfect filmic chemical had bought
out magazine management in 1963 where
mama became a standout publication with
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby introducing the
x-men spider-man the Fantastic Four and
the Avengers because of financial issues
unaccounted for by public documents in
1969 perfect filming Chemical reported a
profit loss of 35 million dollars
leading to a name change in 1973 under
CEO Sheldon Feinberg and the new company
titled cadance industries while
financial problems continued with Marvel
helping to keep the company afloat to a
degree the consistent profit losses led
to cadence industries complete
bankruptcy and liquidation in 1986
because model was one of the
subsidiaries of cadence industries at
the time during the liquidation sales
former editor-in-chief Jim shooter
attended to purchase the company but was
outbid by Ronald Perelman and new world
pictures as a result Jim shooter and
several others acquired financing from
venture capitalist firm triumph capital
a company that lends money to fledgling
businesses while maintaining a
controlling stake with the expectation
of financial returns once they're off
the ground using the money provided
shooter established Voyager
communications as a parent company that
focused on creating comical counterparts
to Nintendo and professional wrestling
video games like concepts using the
fledgling popularity as a platform in
1991 a valiant comics was introduced as
a working imprint of Voyager and after
reaching out to existing publishers like
gold key comics attained the licenses
necessary to write and release the
publication's of Magnus robot fighter
and solar man of the atom
because the titles were so well received
Dahlia began working on original titles
to establish itself as a legitimate
competitor to both DC and Marvel to this
end between 1991 1992 valiant created
and released stories revolving around X
amount of war Wray Shadow Man
Harbinger Archer and Armstrong as well
as eternal warrior using this as a
jumping-off platform and because each of
these characters existed in their own
comics and August the September of 1992
valiant launched the line wide unity
storyline as a way to crossover their
various characters and provide a more
cohesive universe this combined with the
groundbreaking concept of zero issues
which serve to provide origins for their
characters meant that the popularity of
value was boosted across the board
leading to XO Man O'War shattering
records by selling over 900,000 copies
punk unity as opposed to 60,000 copies
before unity as a result in 1992 Diet
was named new publisher of the year and
1993 it was named publisher of the year
over both Marvel and DC and monthly
pricing guides such as wizard magazine
Overstreet and others recorded various
accolades which in turn drove the prices
of values comics even higher with some
of the pre unity comics selling for $100
or more due to the fact that there were
so few originally printed looking to
capitalize on the popularity of Voyager
communications in the diet line of
comics triumphs capital so Voyager
communications and all of its
subsidiaries to acclaim entertainment
for 65 million dollars the reason for
this purchase was at acclaim plan to
further the valiant titles by tying the
value comic line over into its video
games and other entertainment media
however shortly after the acquisition
the sales of comic books came to a
screeching halt due to the comic bust of
the 1990s Jamie back to 1976 and the
introduction of the Overstreet buyer's
guide prior to this time a national
standard for tracking the value of
comics did not exist instead a comic
collecting was largely regional with
collectors traveling to local
conventions stores or homes of other
collectors and training their comics
based on their perceived value however
following the advent of the Overstreet
buyer's guide which served to establish
the value of comics based on their
rarity and condition collectors around
the country had become aware of rare or
important comic books that could be
worth large sums of money owing to the
fact that so few remained in quality
condition after they released to the
general public what this meant was at
stories like 19
five s giant-size x-men issue number one
and 1985's crisis on Infinite Earths
worth a lot of money if they were in
good condition while classic stories
like 1962 is amazing fantasy number 15
were worth even more money with the most
pristine copy valued at over 1 million
dollars following this revelation
speculators began looking to purchase
the next comic that would hopefully be
worth a fortune artificially inflating
the kelley book market and the process
by collecting multiple copies of college
deemed to be extremely popular among
readers but would have a huge impact on
characters as so by 1994 following the
death of Superman and Batman nightfall
story arc respectively
collectors had purchased the stories in
droves looking to the value they would
hold in the future however the opposite
effect happened in that Marvel and DC as
well as value due to their post unity
popularity began producing massive
amounts of comics and in turn the value
of comics plummeted due to an
oversaturation of the market as a result
by late 1995 pre-orders for comics are
reaching the lowest point of the decade
and the titles of Valiant Comics under
acclaim were no exception recognizing
the situation they were in and that
action needs to be taken to revitalize
interest in their titles in late 1996
acclaimed relaunched the dying comics
line as acclaimed comics of valiant
heroes while the names and titles
belonging to EXO Manowar bloodshot and
Shadow Man were the same the stories of
the acclaimed valiant lineup were
launched as a new universe which was
more easily adapted into video games
furthermore in 2000 acclaimed launched
the second Unity saga as a six-part
story arc to unify the pre and post
acclaim valiant universes by eliminating
their least popular titles and keeping
the most popular ones
however acclaim stopped producing this
series after only half of the books
released due in part to a public payment
problem with the artists and severe
losses from a recently released for its
video game to sidetrack here during the
late 1990s acclaim was a sole provider
of video games based on the World
Wrestling Federation
but because the WWF was competing with
WCW during the Monday Night Wars the
contests relating to sports
entertainment supremacy extended to
merchandise as well with WCW under the
banner of video game developer THQ and
experiencing record profits due to the
high quality of their games in late 1999
the WWF suffered its contract with
acclaim and Al
itself with THQ this combined with a
series of bad business decisions like
failing to pay royalties to mary-kate
and Ashley Olsen for games developed and
sold by claim in addition to the attempt
of boosting the popularity of the BMX
line by introducing a xxx variant which
included nudity all led to a claim
filing for chapter 7 bankruptcy
resulting in an auction of assets during
which time the licenses of Magnus robot
fighter and solar man of the atom return
to Western publishing so by 2005 Dinesh
Shonda Soddy and Jason Kothari two
students from the University of Southern
California and Pennsylvania's Wharton
School of Business were able to acquire
the rights to Valiant Comics during the
auction of acclaim entertainment during
this time Valiant Comics was rebranded
civilian entertainment and over the next
seven years the two began reaching out
to veterans of the comic book industry
and geek culture by bringing in
individuals like Peter Cuneo
the former Marvel CEO who brought the
company out of bankruptcy following the
comic bust of the 1990s and Josh Jones
who took over the role of digital sales
and special projects management
furthermore in an effort to live up to
its idea of valuing the past while
looking to the future Diet relaunched
their new lineup of comics in two phases
the first came in 2012 during an event
titled the summer of valiant which took
place between May and August and was
initiated with a launch of XO Man O'War
debuting with issue number one of a solo
series the title was handed over to
Robert Venditti best known for his work
on DC's Green Lantern and the flash at
the time of his hiring for Valiant
Comics indeed he had established himself
as a New York Times bestselling author
where the surrogates the graphic novel
adaptation of Percy Jackson and the
Olympians and the homeland directive
looking to the previous volumes of XO
Man O'War prior to the relaunch a
valiant entertainment the character of
XO Man O'War experienced a wholesale
reboot and was based loosely on the
previous source material but also
allowed valiant and Venditti
to provide prospective readers with
where the new valiant era had to offer
picking up in pool incheon northern
italy in 402 a.d the story blended both
science fiction and nonfiction by
providing a battle between the Visigoths
and the romans to sidetrack hear and
delve into a bit of real world history
the Western Roman Empire was established
around 30 years before modern era
following the death of Julius Caesar and
the collapse of the RO
Republic where the Western Roman Empire
itself had lasted around 506 years this
period of the comic represents the
beginning of the Empire's end do to Rome
conquering the Austrian Dutch English
German Icelandic Norwegian and Swedish
territories who are collectively known
as the Visigoths now where there is no
particular reason for the decline of the
Western Roman Empire and the historians
point to a multitude of factors
including the idea that the Empire had
grown too large to control as well as
economic religious and civil reasons
somebody to take note of is that the
Visigoths as they're depicted in this
story aren't actually designed to be a
combination of northern European nations
uniting against Rome and instead are
simply just a society called the
Visigoths
but the inclusion of this bit of history
into the story provides us with an idea
of the research that went into including
real world history as a way to ground
the characters of the valiant universe
and make them more relatable now where
Erick himself is depicted as being brave
and headstrong albeit a bit foolish and
that he disobeyed his uncle's orders to
hold the line and keep from attacking
the Romans the reason behind this logic
is revealed when Erik learns that the
frontal assault from the Romans was a
distraction while the rest of the army
routed the Visigoths and attack their
camp from behind
forcing retreat and assuming to escape
certain doom in the midst of the attack
Erik's father's mortally wounded now the
conversation between Erik and his dying
father are of extreme importance here
and the reason why is because Ben Duty
is following the classic example of the
hero's journey the side track here and
the realm of narration and comparative
mythology which is to say the comparison
of myths from different cultures
virtually all societies have some
measure of storytelling involving a
person of the religion rising up to
become a hero where the circumstances of
this change from one culture to the next
the overarching theme remains the same
the matically the hero's journey
involves a normal man or woman receiving
a call to adventure they received
supernatural aid they pass the threshold
of the known to the unknown they receive
help from an unexpected source after
which they encounter a mentor from here
they face a series of challenges and
temptations after which they face a
personal revelation in which they die
and are reborn as a villain they slowly
experience a reformation from a villain
back to a hero and then they atone for
their past actions and the cycle repeats
itself with regards to Erik this is a
pattern that I'd like you to keep in the
back of your mind and that with the
Vista
camp having been over ran and its
inhabitants being taken by the Romans
Erik's call to adventure came when his
father died and he sought to gain
revenge by killing as many Romans as
possible now where the attention of Erik
is drawn to reports of Romans wandering
the countryside and preparing to attack
after Erik and a group of soldiers
investigate instead of fighting Romans
they discover the presence of an alien
race called the vine rubber Venditti
begins to transition away from the
historical roots of the story and draw
on various characters from colleagues in
general who helped to form the idea
behind Erik what I mean here is that for
those of you who are familiar with the
character of Thor you may notice that
both he and Erik share very similar
personality traits and there's an
explicit reason for this when looking at
heroes who originate with historical
times especially those in ancient Greek
Roman and Norwegian times Thor usually
stands as the embodiment of ancient
themes involving camaraderie bravery and
occasional foolishness now I don't mean
to say the robber Venditti is actually
ripping off the character of for instead
much like Superman and his embodiment of
the modern hero archetype heroes who are
designed to hail from earlier days in
human history tend to be modeled after
the personality or actions of Thor since
he oftentimes was used as a model of
what it meant to be a true soldier among
the Norwegian people having said that
where the story would go on to see Erik
and a handful of his men taken aboard
the vessel and into the depths of space
to work as slaves his time on the vessel
so I'm experiencing a series of
extremely violent acts including the
dead being recycled as a food source for
the living now where this pattern
continued for the next several thousand
years during his time and after plotting
their escape from the line Erik and his
group were provided a map of the alien
ship by one of the workers leading them
directly to the armory and a means to
use the vines weapons against them and
so with one of the vine soldiers
arriving the following morning for Erik
and his crew to continue their working
duties after faking the death of one of
their men the vine alien is overtaken
and killed after which a means of escape
is provided taking to the armory and
discovering the exo-armor what Vin de T
tells us here is that the armor itself
is considered sacred by the vine race
but is also sentient and that those who
have tried to wear it but were found
unworthy were killed by the suit now
something I want to do here is focus on
what rubber Venditti actually tells us
about the exo-armor where it's full
abilities would be expanded on over the
of the Manowar publications in the
present moment the armor contained
regenerative properties and that Eric's
hand was rebuilt in addition to being
impervious to the weapons of the by
themselves as well as surviving the
depths of space and travelling to
various locations in accordance with the
wishes of Eric this is shown when the
attempted escape of the prisoners is
thwarted by the blind soldiers who kill
everyone but Eric due to the suits
protection returning and kind by
eliminating most of the vine soldiers on
the ship
following this final battle and desiring
to return back to Rome where he arrives
in the modern day so following his
arrival on earth
Robert Venditti began the true task of
giving us as the reader a whole EU new
take on the character in the realm of
comics absent the standards created by
Marvel in DC where Eric's departure from
earth took place around 402 ad because
the bind mother should have been
traveling throughout the cosmos at light
speeds while only a few years have
passed on the ship itself life on earth
had moved forward by almost 1,600 years
meaning that with his return Eric's wife
children and people were all dead to
this end eric was quite literally a man
at a time and it took me to understand
his place in the new world using the
exosuits fantastic powers using the EXO
Man O'War title as a flagship line for
valiant over the course of the next
several story arcs including hunter and
hunted uneasy alliances and planet death
leading up to the events of unity EXO
mana wars role on earth was modified and
adjusted follow the hero's journey but
also allow value to tie him into
introductions of their own heroes and
expand on the valiant universe and the
story hunter and hunted when the
Beinecke station of their own operatives
on earth disguised as humans a British
operative named Colin king operating
under the name nin jak was reintroduced
to the valiant universe serving as an
indirect agent of the vine and their
efforts to capture Eric and return the
exo-armor or the story arc would go on
to scene in Jack discovering the nature
of the vine their true motives and
eventually a-lying himself with Eric
this story saw the creation of Alexander
Dorian by robert van diddy
going into uneasy alliances where dorian
served as a member of the bind who
defected from their cause
using the knowledge of alexander to gain
a better understanding of how deep the
vines influence went on earth the uneasy
alliances story arc led into dorian nin
Jack and Eric all attending to root out
the very
vine operatives on earth culminating in
the launch of prelude to planet death in
that lab Irvin Diddy had returned eros
closest friend gasps he to the landscape
by revealing that he had actually
survived the initial escape assault and
was being tortured by the vine for
information or the prelude focus on the
vine using the acquired information to
launch an attack against Earth Gaffney
had sacrificed his life for the purpose
of destroying the vine mothership and
ending the invasion now the reason why
robert Venditti
included this bit of information into
the story was due to the fact that at
the time in the publication history of
Erik his character was still largely the
same as he had been since his
introduction because the hero's journey
requires that the hero in question
experience a kind of fall from grace
vended he had reasoned that in order to
take Erik along to this next step the
vine we need to be removed from the
equation which in turn would allow
bendata to focus on Erik himself to this
end the planet death event saw Erik
donning the exo Man O'War Armour and
after realizing that the vine would
consistently pursue him in order to
reclaim the suit waged a war against
their entire race on their home planet
alone arriving on their planet but
finding the priesthood in the midst of a
civil war between those who believed
this who chose Erik and those who didn't
after inciting a rebellion using the
slaves who had previously been held
captive a massive battle ensued which
resulted in the vine being pushed to the
point of near extinction leaving behind
only those who refused to follow Erik
back to earth now where the events
contained within these first fourteen
issues remain isolated to the exo
Manowar line itself the idea at the time
was that each of the individual
characters and teams released by valiant
would experience a planned one-year arc
establishing their basis after which a
series of annual crossovers would be
initiated among the various groups to
this end and beginning in November of
under writer Matt Ken Diane introduced
the unity line of comics which centered
on livewire who can control machines the
eternal warrior who exists is one of
three genuine immortals and the British
agent nin jack all of whom are brought
together under the leadership of
toyohara the most powerful psionic on
earth
possessing a range of abilities
including telepathy telekinesis and
mind-control covered in the crossover
event to kill a king with the vine
threat neutralized and after returning
to earth because the underlying goal of
Toyo Harada was to conquer the earth and
secret when Erik had taken over Romania
and declared
the new territory of Visigoths and
decreed the Romanian people to be his
subjects unity had been formed to
neutralize a threat of Eric and Reese
were ordered to Romania receiving
critical acclaim for its pacing art and
storytelling and that to kill a king
focused largely on Eric's inner struggle
in his need to see mr. Gough returned
juxtaposed with the recognition that he
existed in a new world with a story
concluded by seeing livewire seize
control of the exo-armor from Eric but
also learning a Hirata's goal to conquer
the world much like the formation of the
Avengers whose members were manipulated
at the hands of Loki the members of
unity turned on Hirata and inducted Eric
into their ranks allowing value to
transform the team into their variation
of the Avengers or the Justice League
now where the exo Manowar series went
forward with issue number 26 initiating
the three-part series armor hunters
followed by enter the all Marines dead
hand and exodus because valiant look to
ensure it did not fall into the
situation of confusing and convoluted
story lines as was seen with other
content creators instead diet structures
publications based on two elements fan
reception and easily accessible content
where existing readers of the value
universe were able to guide new fans by
providing reading lists and information
on where to start dying itself also look
to ensure that those fans who did not
have access to these reading groups
would not feel alienated by the various
comics and crossovers launched in
December of 2014 as a four part
self-contained miniseries written by
Jeff Lemire and Matt ken the valiant
served to offer a jumping-off platform
for prospective readers by focusing on
eternal warrior geomancer bloodshot
Armstrong Neville Alcott and XO Man
O'War receiving critical acclaim yet
again from one up com Comic Book
Resources Bloody Disgusting and other
geek culture related websites due to the
miniseries providing the origins of the
starring characters a display of their
abilities as well as their view of the
world the valiant miniseries saw a fresh
influx of prospective readers who were
finding themselves growing apart from
the larger-than-life characters stories
and teams found within the pages of
Marvel and DC proper in addition to this
where these crossovers were and remain
extremely well received by fans of the
valiant universe die in itself has
consistently maintained the idea of
ensuring that each of these characters
are allowed to grow and develop
adequately
on their own well this doesn't mean the
valiant avoided cross lowers between
their individual characters it did mean
that much like DC's format with
individual character story arcs valiant
sought to ensure that those who
preferred EXO maddewar outside of his
involvement with unity ninja and other
characters were able to see their desire
fulfilled by reading his own individual
story lines in his title comic without
concern of the series falling prey to
becoming a massively confusing series of
cameos with that being said we're going
to bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later please
the problem was strange things often
happened around Harry and it was just no
good telling the Dursleys he didn't make
them happen once and petunia tired of
Harry coming back from the barbers
looking as though he hadn't been at all
but taking a pair of kitchen scissors
and cut his hair so short he was almost
bald except for his bangs which he left
to hide that horrible scar Dudley had
laughed himself